PROFESSOR: OK, all right,
so just very briefly,
I just wanted to remind
you because it goes along
with the video,
bioluminescence is
light emitted based on
a biochemical reaction.
The most common one is
the enzyme luciferase,
which reacts with a
molecule called luciferin
to undergo a biochemical
transformation that uses ATP.
And as a result of
that transformation,
there is light emitted.
So you don't have to
shine light onto these.
The light comes from the
biochemical reaction.
So the assays and a
lot of biological work
is based on the luciferin,
luciferase reaction,
so the mushrooms that do this
will have both luciferase
and luciferin.
So in an organism, you can
transfect-- or in cells,
you can transfect
cells with luciferase,
and then when you're
ready to do the--
to see the luminescence,
the bioluminescence,
you can add luciferin
exogenously,
and there's a number
of chemists that
are trying to make
modified systems that
have different light
energies and so on.
So there's a lot of
protein engineering
that's taking place based on
the luciferin/luciferase pair.
There's all kinds of cool
biochemistry going on there,
OK?
Anyone who comes in could
come and grab a donut.
We can move them, or
do you want a donut?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, all right.
I didn't mean to
call attention to--
OK, I want to go briefly
back to arrays, DNA arrays,
because I want to explain to you
the power of this technology.
So last time, we were talking
about arrays which are
basically printed layouts,
and I'm-- this is going to be
a very tiny array with
six sites on the array.
So it's a two by three array.
The ones that are
used in biology
are way larger than that.
You can see those up here--
far, far more spots, and this is
just the size of a glass slide
and at each of
these sites, there
would be different
DNA sequences.
So they're specific
DNA sequences,
and they are printed
onto the array with--
it was originally done
just with printers.
Now there's more technological
ways of handling this,
and they're usually on
silicon or glass slides.
So there's a lot of engineering
went into the original arrays
to make these really packed
tight distribution of DNAs.
And these would be what are
called addressed arrays.
We know what's at
each of the sites.
We're aware of the sequences
at each of the sites,
and there's really
cool chemistry
that would have enabled the
disposition of these arrays.
So what these
arrays are used for
is to probe complementary
pieces of DNA.
So let's say we've
got a GHIJ that
come potentially from genomic
DNA, and they complement--
each of them complement one
of the sites on the J-K--
complement one of the
sites on the array,
but the DNA that
you're screening
is specifically labeled
with a fluorophore, OK?
So these would be
fluorophore labeled,
and arrays enable you to
do is to rapidly screen
either genomic DNA or,
actually, much more usefully,
as you'll know now, the
transcriptome, so the messenger
RNAs, and I'm going to
remind you about technology
to take the messenger
RNAs from cells
and then make them
an appropriate copy
of a complementary DNA
to what's on the arrays.
So let's go take a look
at the next slide which
describes the experiment.
So let's say you want to
screen populations of cells
where one set of
cells is cancerous
and the other one is healthy.
You would collect the
lysate from those cells.
messenger RNA presumably
based on a tag or a feature
of the messenger RNA
that's common to
just the messenger.
What would that be?
What would be common to the
mature messenger RNA that
would allow you to capture
just the messenger RNA,
not all the other RNAs, not DNA.
Anyone?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The poly-A tail.
So you can, with an
appropriate resin,
for example, a
poly-T support, you
can capture that all,
and then in each case,
you would take the
messenger RNA collection,
and then what you
need to do is turn it
into a complementary
DNA sequence.
We're much happier
screening at the DNA level
because the RNA is less stable.
So it's really handy
to do that conversion,
and you use the viral enzyme,
reverse transcriptase.
That's an enzyme that comes
from the retroviruses that
are exemplified by
the HIV retrovirus
that we'll be talking about
in the last week of class.
So you'll learn where reverse
transcriptase fits in the life
cycle of the HIV virus.
Then once you've
collected the DNA that's
complementary to the RNA
from each type of cell,
you label them
uniquely, for example,
with green fluorophores
or red fluorophores.
It's kind of a global
reaction you just paste--
chemically link the
fluorophore to each set of DNA.
And then you basically
combine everything
and take a look at how
the chips, how the arrays,
light up.
So your typical experiment
would be everywhere
you've got something that
has a red fluorophore might
bind to a unique site.
Everything with a
green fluorophore
might bind to another
unique site on the array.
And then if both types of
DNA binding to the same site,
that would show up as yellow.
If nobody is binding, it
would show up as a blank spot.
So you get these collections
where, pretty easily, you
can look at thousands
of sequences
to see whether
they're complementary.
That's on your array.
Everywhere you see
yellow, the cancer cell
and the healthy cell, a
binding kind of equally,
so there's nothing
disease related there.
So that's an interesting
feature because you can say,
well, none of these are
problematic segments,
but then you see very clearly
spots that are clearly red.
So the sequences of the DNA
on the glass or silicon chip
are complementary
to sequences that
are unique to the mRNA
in the cancer genome,
in the cancer cell
line from that lyaste.
So it's pretty cool.
I don't know if any of
you have hit that link,
but it's basically this
guy is sitting at a bench
and doing an experiment where
he's able to do thousands--
the equivalent of thousands and
thousands of experiments just
by using one gene chip
to do the probing.
In other cases, you will
see spots that are green,
which mean they come exclusively
from the healthy cells.
So those would be really the
ones you want to interrogate,
and where it's black,
nothing's binding,
so it's less important.
So it allows you to go from a
grid of thousands and thousands
of different sequences
to pick out suspects
in a disease-related situation.
Does that makes sense?
Pretty cool technology.
The original chips were called--
they were from, I think,
Affymetrix, the Affy chips,
and they are really widely
used even to this day,
and there are different
types of variations,
but I think one
of the most useful
and ones that will remind you
of certain things we've talked
about in the class
is that you can
grow cells of different sort
of, you know, histories.
For example, you
collect the messenger
RNA because, remember,
the transcriptome is
much more interesting
to us than the genome.
The chips would have
to be a lot bigger
to scan all of the
genome, and then you
use reverse transcriptase
to make a complementary DNA
of the RNA because it's
more stable, more tractable
to work with, and then you
put on a fluorophore label,
mix everything together,
and see what you get.
So those are my candidate spots.
So if you had an
experiment, let me think--
walk you through what
the arrays can do,
but let's make sure we know
what they can't do because it's
always important
whenever someone says,
I got this technology.
It's going to solve all
the problems of the world.
Throw away or your
beakers and test tubes.
You just don't need
to do any of that,
and you can solve
everything with arrays.
So let's say you've got a
situation that, in some cases,
although genes may be
defective, the messenger
is still produced, OK?
So there's something wrong,
but you make the messenger RNA.
So it would still kind of
show up normally on the chip,
but the gene defect prevents
translation into proteins.
So you get the gene, but
you can't translate it,
so it's going to look
like a normal gene,
but it's in the translation
from the track--
from the messenger RNA to the
protein where things go wrong.
What are you going
to see on the array?
Is it going to look healthy?
Is it going to look not healthy?
What's going to be the outcome?
Could I use an array, a DNA
array, for this experiment?
Yeah?
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, Yeah.
It's just going to look like
everything binds to the chip.
It's not going to
be informative.
So in this case, you need to do
very different experiments that
are at the protein
level, all right?
So I want you to
remember that these
are very good to get the genomic
sequence, the messenger RNA
sequence.
But if you've got, for example,
a protein that is made,
and there's a problem
with, let's say,
a phosphorylation
by a kinase that
may be critical for
function in a cell,
you will not see
that in the array.
That will not be visible.
You'd have to do different
types of experiments,
for example, with
phosphoproteins,
specific antibodies
to tell that there was
a disorder in those systems.
So always when
someone tells you,
I've got this great experiment,
you say, what can it do?
That is awesome, but
what can't it do?
OK, I need to worry
about that, all right?
OK, so what we've
seen so far is we've
seen a variety of
fluorescent tools,
for example, to
label the nucleus,
either the original ethidium
bromide types of stains that
will intercalate into DNA and
give you a fluorescent signal
that could be seen on a gel.
We've seen the evolution
of ethidium bromide
to less toxic materials,
for example, the DAPI stain.
So ethidium bromide
intercalates--
ethidium-- sorry, DAPI
binds in the minor groove.
And we saw images
of that last time.
One important
distinction that is
made with these kinds
of dyes is that DAPI
is what's known as a
supravital dye, which
means you can use that dye
and observe live cells.
So supravital is associated
with the types of experiments
that you can do observing
cells that are still alive.
The ethidium bromide
is not such a dye,
and neither are the antibodies
because so ethidium bromide is
toxic, so even though
the ethidium bromide gets
into cells, it
actually should have
the H here because that would
be ethyl bromide in my language.
So ethidium bromide
has the H there.
You can't use that.
It's not a supravital dye
because it's toxic to cells
because intercalates in the
DNA and disrupts replication,
so that is not
supravital, so DAPI is.
This guy isn't, and
antibodies, which
we learned a little bit
about last time, these
are from my
description, are simply
reagents to recognize components
of biological systems, most
commonly, proteins,
and now we're
getting better at
making antibodies
to carbohydrates or glycans.
Are antibodies supravital
or not, and why--
if they're not, why?
Could I use that on a cell
and follow a live cell
with an antibody?
Yeah?
Carmen?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't
seem very likely to me
that the antibodies will
allow the proteins to do
whatever it is that they do.
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: So I think
that the cells would die.
PROFESSOR: So it's a correct--
they are not supravital.
What do you think
would happen if I add
an antibody to a living cell?
Could it stain-- it could stain
something on the cell surface,
but it might, as
you say, interfere
with the function of the cell.
Let's say I have an antibody
to the epidermal growth factor
receptor.
That is going to
alter the properties.
So you're correct
in that respect.
What about targets inside cells?
Are the antibodies
going to get in?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a big wall, frankly.
It's an impenetrable
barrier to get in.
So you can really
only stain in--
you can only observe in what
are known as fixed cells.
And when we call a
cell a fixed cell,
we actually mean we've broken
it because what we've done
is we've treated the cell
population with methanol,
which pokes holes all over
the cellular membranes.
They're fixed.
They're static on a slide.
They're not going to
move around anymore,
and you can stain
with antibodies.
You can tell what
happened at the moment--
what was happening at
the moment the cell
passed away, if you
will, what was going on,
which proteins were there.
But you can't keep
observing moving forward
because the cells then are
no longer viable, all right?
So neither of these
approaches are super vital,
but they're for
different reasons.
One is toxicity.
The other one is also toxicity,
as Carmen pointed out,
but it's also a problem
with membrane permeability.
So what we're going to
talk about in the rest
of this lecture is
a way to get around
this impenetrable
problem, and this--
and the discovery of the
green fluorescent protein,
and we're really mostly about
GFP and its close siblings
that might be different colors.
What I want to walk you
through is the discovery
of the protein,
and I really want
to impress upon you how science
happens in funny, small steps
early on.
You could never have
predicted that a jellyfish
off the coast of
Seattle was going
to revolutionize biology,
biochemistry, life sciences,
right?
Who would have ever
thought of that?
And so that's why, you
know, they colleagues, we
and our colleagues, are so
excited about fundamental
science where you don't quite
know where you're going,
but you're working
on something cool,
and then the prepared
mind goes, wow!
That's interesting.
I could use that
for this problem.
So Shimamura was a
Japanese biochemist,
who was fascinated by jellyfish
and their bioluminescence
and worked for years, slaved
away for years and years.
Apparently, he would
go with his family
to the small islands
in Puget Sound
and have his kids go and
collect jellyfish all day
long because he noticed certain
things about the jellyfish that
were rather intriguing with
respect to their properties.
And the key thing
that was observed
was that there is a
bioluminescent protein
in jellyfish known as aequorin.
So that's the kind of
luminescence we just
described, but in the
dark, there was also
a fluorescence species,
and it turns out
that the light energy
from a aequorin
actually can excite
the flourophore
in the green
fluorescent protein,
and then you emit the light of
the wavelength in the green.
So it was actually a couple
pair of proteins, aequorin
and the second
thing that was just
the green fluorescent protein,
and what was fascinating
about this protein is more
and more work was done
is they didn't seem
to need any additives.
So for bioluminescence,
you got to add ATP,
and you've got to add,
you know, the luciferin.
You've got to add things
to see the fluorescence.
What was unique about the
green fluorescent protein
is it didn't need
anything to add.
You just had the protein,
and it was fluorescent.
So what I want to
talk to you about
is the molecular basis
of this fluorescent,
and we'll also talk, though,
about the protein engineering
that was systematically done
to make this more and more
of a useful reagent.
So Shimamura was
the first person.
He had his kids collect
so many jellyfish
that they could extract the
green fluorescent protein
through traditional
old-school biochemical methods
and grow crystals,
protein crystals.
Guess what?
They are bright green, and we're
able to solve the structure.
Once they had the
structure, they sort of
knew what was going
on with the jellyfish,
and they were also able to
recognize a particular part
of the sequence of the green
fluorescent protein that
ended up being the
precursor to the fluorophore
that we see nowadays
and we understand.
Originally, the protein
was not monomeric.
I'll talk to you a
bit about that later.
For technology, it's
much more handy to have
this protein as a monomore,
not as a dimer or a tetramer.
That makes experiments
complicated,
but I'll show you
a very easy trick
that was done to fix that.
And so the other people
who shared Nobel Prize
with Shimamura, who, by the
way, passed away just a couple
of weeks ago, in fact,
but a an amazing old age.
It must have been all
that digging for jellyfish
that helped him live that long.
There was also Martin
Chalfie at Columbia,
who demonstrated that the
gene for the green fluorescent
protein could be put in
all kinds of other animals,
organisms, C elegans bacteria
and they would fluoresce.
And a really major player
in this entire story
was Roger Tsien, who died
very young of a stroke, who
was the chemist-biochemist who
put the pieces together said,
if this is GFP, we can use it
for so many different things.
So he really advanced
the technologies
of the applications.
So protein expression could be--
they realized quite early on
could just be programmed
into a protein
by just having the DNA for the
green fluorescent protein stuck
on to a favorite
protein of interest.
Then you would have that DNA
be transcribed, translated
in the cell, and then your
favorite protein in the cell
would fluoresce
green because it was
attached as a construct
with the other proteins.
So all of those things
became enabled quite quickly.
This could be done in all
organisms, eukaryotes,
prokaryotes.
It's pretty non-toxic, so
expressing a bunch of GFP
in a cell doesn't kill it.
That's kind of handy.
So it really is a
super vital system,
and it's visible in
all kinds of tissues.
So what I'm going
to show you here
are some of the seminal results,
first of all, the structure
we'll talk about
and then Chalfie
was able to put the DNA
into proteins and bacteria,
and, also, proteins that
were labeled in C elegans.
And the story of Chalfie
is kind of funny.
He's one of those guys who
sort of didn't necessarily
have all the
equipment he needed,
but he knew this
was really exciting,
and he needed a
fluorescence microscope.
So he would call up
all the companies who
sold microscopes
and, say, I'm really
thinking of buying this
fluorescent microscope.
This particular one would be--
these are a couple
of hundred grand,
you know, these are
not cheap things.
And he'd talk the company into
putting a microscope in his lab
for a month as a demo.
It's, like, you know,
saying to the car
dealer you want to buy a car and
then driving a Ferrari around
for a month and then
saying, it's not really
going to work for me.
So he collected
all his early data
on microscopes that were on
loan from Olympus and Leica
and various other places.
So that's a funny, funny twist.
OK, so the fluorophore--
all right, so they could go
from DNA to protein sequence.
Then they could look
at the structure
and see that the place in the
protein sequence that went
serine, tyrosine, glycine.
So here we go--
serine, tyrosine.
You recognize that one.
It's the one with one
of the aromatic rings,
glycine is the one
with no substituent.
It was common in a
number of organisms,
mostly aquatic organisms
that fluoresce and seem
to be the origin of
the flourophore in GFP,
and so the chemists got to work,
and you know what chemists do,
they start drawing arrows and
joining bonds and figuring out
how can we go from something
that's basically dead,
and it's not got any
fluorescence at all
for something
that's fluorescent.
And so from the structure and
from working out the mechanism,
they basically found that this
little piece, this tripeptide
within the entire structure
of the DNA primary sequence,
was able to cyclize through
that nitrogen attacking
that carbon and
then an elimination,
and then there was an
oxygen-dependent oxidation
to give you this structure.
So if you look at this, you
can still see the serine.
You kind of know
this was tyrosine,
but it doesn't look
like it anymore,
and it turns out the glycine
was incredibly important.
It doesn't look like it's
involved in the chromophore,
but when you have a
glycine in a sequence,
it allows you to do
some funny twists
and turns because it
has no substituents.
So it allowed that loop to form.
Once that loop is formed,
chemistry can occur.
If the glycine
wasn't there, things
might be not in
an ideal situation
to form the fluorophore.
The oxidation to put
in that double bond
is oxygen dependent.
So in some cases,
the fluorophore
would mature a bit more slowly.
So you would go from
the free state that's
not fluorescent to
the fluorescent state
quite slowly if you
withheld oxygen.
So a lot of engineering was done
to improve the maturation time,
to improve the photo physics.
There's really cool
photophysical experiments that
were done, but that's
the basis of it,
and the emission of
this flouorophore,
you can almost recognize that
it's a fluorophore because it's
got a lot of what's
called conjugation
in organic chemistry--
one double bond,
another double bond
stuck onto this ring with
multiple double bonds.
And it emits at the same--
a similar wavelength
to the fluorophore fluoroscein,
so people were happy
because all the filters
on their microscopes
were the right ones.
If you just used the fluoroscein
filters, you would get a GFPC.
So that really was made
in heaven for those guys.
OK, so let's take
a look at this.
Here's the wire diagram of
the original crystallized
structure.
I've planted a ribbon on there.
I get rid of all
the side chains,
so you see this beautiful
dimer structure.
Let's throw away
one of the dimers,
and you can start to look.
There's a little
something sneaky in there,
and as you get closer, you can
start to see the structure.
There's this sort of
thread going through it.
That's just a trace
of the backbone,
but there is the structure
of the fluorophore.
Here's the fluorophore
with the space filling,
and what I think is kind of
cool is if you kind of twist
the GFP around, it's
kind of like a barrel,
and it looks like
a bird in a cage
because it's caged in there.
And to be honest,
it's the structure.
It's not just the structure
of the flourophore.
It's the fact that the
fluorophore is inside
a kind of hydrophobic
environment
that makes it fluoresce.
I could go into the lab
and make that flourophore
and have it in a
beaker of methanol,
and you wouldn't see anything.
It's only in that environment
that's created in the GFP
molecule, so it's fascinating.
The structure of GFP creates
the shape to cyclize,
and it creates the environment
for good fluorescence.
So he has a mass of animals
that have been labeled with GFP.
As you've seen, our mouse has
been labeled multiple times.
This was the first GFP rabbit.
He was known as Alba.
He even had his own
name, but there's
seaweeds and zebrafish and
mice from a letter, C elegans,
the famous, the fly.
What else?
I don't even know what these
things are, but Purkinje cells
and so on.
Anyway, so this shows you
the universality of the tool.
A brief mention about
the dimer problem, people
looked at the structure
of the diamond
from the crystal
structure and found
that there was a sticky face
between two monomers of GFP
that encouraged this
quaternary structure.
And so they simply
changed two alanines that
were sitting right at
the dimer interface, one
from one monomer and
one from the other,
created a sticky patch.
Sounds a bit like
hemoglobin, if you remember,
the sickle cell hemoglobin.
They changed them to
lycines and [INAUDIBLE]
solved you had just
monomeric protein
because when you do a lot
of experiments with GFP,
you don't want GFP randomly
dimerizing because it's
going to change the biology of
the protein it's attached to.
So this very, very easy
structure-driven engineering
was perfect.
OK, so let's take a look at
some of the early things that
could be done now.
We take it all for
granted, but GFP
can be used as a reporter
gene to do a number of things
in cellular systems.
So, for example, if you want
to study a regulatory sequence
to know whether this
promoter works well,
you can put it at the
front end of the GFP gene
and then see if the promoter
works under certain conditions,
then the GFP will be produced.
The cells will grow green.
And this is a nice variant
to a luciferase-based system
or a LacZ based system
where you're actually
having to treat and
fix things in order
to do the LacZ experiments.
So here's a really nice
example with C elegans.
What you could do pre-GF--
we really have--
it's like ADBC--
you know, anti whatever before
year 0 and after year 0.
The biological world is pre
GFP and post GFP, frankly,
the impact that it's
had on the system.
So here is a C elegans.
As you know, all the neurons
have names, and a lot of C
elegans biologists are
very familiar with each,
you know, single cell within
the C elegans, in particular,
the neurons.
So this is a listing
of the touch receptors.
You could have an
antibody to those,
and so you could do
some antibody staining,
but antibody staining, remember,
we got to fix the worms.
They don't like that.
You literally fix them
down and do the staining
with the antibody to
get inside the C elegans
to see the antibody
light up the proteins.
You could do beta-gal activity,
same thing, but in both cases,
these are dead C elegans.
They're fixed.
They're in place.
You can't observe
them going forward.
But look instead,
that the images you
would get with GFP, where
you could totally pick out
all the touch receptors.
And this is a situation
where an important protein
in those cells MEC-17 is
co expressed with GFP,
and you can see this
beautiful image,
and the worms are still alive.
You could totally watch
what was going on with them,
and he just wants
you to know that he's
alive and well and kicking.
OK, now, progress has to happen.
So one green protein
does not a history make.
So, immediately,
with the identity
of the structure
of GFP, I am going
to go back really
quickly to look
at that picture of
the structure for you.
Sorry about this
back and forward.
OK, the chemists realize that
if they change this tyrosine
to some of the other
amino acids that
looked a little bit like it,
like phenylalanine, tryptophan,
and histidine, they might
alter the photophysics
of this structure because
if you put tryptophan there,
there's even more double bonds.
If you put phenylalanine
there, that OH is gone.
So there's really opportunities,
and that's the chemists saying,
I can look at this
protein structure,
and I know the one
thing I can change
is to change that amino
acid back at the DNA level.
So I'm going to change the
codon for tyrosine to the codons
for tryptophan,
phenylalanine, and histidine
and then see what my fluorescent
protein looks like, OK?
Does that make sense?
So it was the one
thing that's obvious.
I can fix this.
So what they did was they
made the series of GFPs,
and they transfected
cells, and they
were able to see that
when you replaced
various residues, for example,
tyrosine to tryptophan,
tyrosine to histidine.
There's a little bit
of variation here,
and don't worry about
this for a minute.
They were able to
create bacteria
that had been transfected
with the mutated GFPs
in order to give them
different colors of bacteria.
So my question to you is,
if you look at these, this
would have been
the original GFP,
except made a
little bit brighter
by a small substitution,
which of these would emit
at the shortest wavelengths.
So just look at
the colors, which
is the shortest
wavelength, which
is the bacterium that
expresses the protein
that emits at the
shortest wavelength.
You'd always be
provided a picture
of the electromagnetic spectrum.
Yeah, out there.
AUDIENCE: The GFP.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the
blue one, exactly.
So you can look at the
spectrum, and you say, OK, I've
got blue down here.
There's that cyan.
It's kind of a blue
green, and then I
move towards the more yellow.
So you can pick it out and
say, it's the lowest energy.
It's the shortest wavelength
emission, the highest energy
emission.
OK, all right, and
these were the variance
that I just described while
I went back to the picture.
So you could make a
blue one with histidine.
You could make a cyan
one with tryptophan.
You could preserve the
green one with tyrosine,
but a change in the
serine to a threonine just
to improve the
photophysics, a long story.
I won't-- I'm happy
to chat about it.
And, in fact, there
was one clever one
where you couldn't really
make the protein yellow,
but if you had the
tyrosine nearby sandwiched
with the tyrosine and
the GFP chromophore,
you could actually go as far
as the yellow flouorphore.
And that, in principle, should
make everybody really thrilled.
It's always this situation
with protein engineering
where you make something,
and it's a huge improvement
and then everyone says,
well, what else, you know?
What's next?
We need red dyes.
We need all kinds
of different dyes.
So teams went back to
the oceans and actually
collected organisms based
on the color they fluoresced
at, nice way to sample things.
And, actually, we were
able to ultimately discover
a red fluorescent protein
from the Discosoma
coral, the original
protein, DS red,
and if you look at
this kind of carefully,
it looks a lot like GFP.
There's the tyrosine,
that funny ring.
There's a double
bond there, but there
is an additional double
bond down further
into the sequence that extends
what we call the chromophore.
And when you extend
the chromophore,
you're more likely to move
to longer wavelengths,
and that's how they got the red,
and then a bunch of engineering
later, they got what's
called the fruits, which emit
at all different wavelengths.
Much of this was
not done rationally
because they went to nature.
They found out what nature did.
They got here, and
then they did a process
known as gene shuffling,
where they mixed
and matched portions
of genes to get them
the entire color spectrum.
They're not all
fabulous fluorophores.
They have some problems.
They bleach easily and so
on, but, nevertheless, this
is a truly amazing
sort of outcome.
OK, so and they enable
you to do art work
with fluorescent
proteins with bacteria,
so you just paint your picture
and wait for the bacteria
to grow, and you would
have all those colors.
So fluorescent
proteins originally
were very limited, originally
just green, then blue-green
and greenish yellow, but,
now, with the palette
that's available, you
can color all kinds
of organelles in different
types of colors, all right?
OK, so now let's take
a couple of things.
When we opened up this
class, we showed you
a bunch of these pictures
because we wanted
you to stay in 7016 with us to
see the cool things you'd see,
and they were pretty much
what we would call eye candy.
They look cool, but
how did we make them?
And, now, with the knowledge
of GFP and RFP and so on,
you can say, OK, I understand
what this experiment is,
and you can certainly
see that this
is a super vital technique.
So what I want to ask is,
what are we looking at?
What is labeled to give
us this beautiful picture?
So you can sort of go down,
and there's a bunch of options,
but, obviously,
anything where you
think you're labeling DNA
with a fluorescent protein
is incorrect.
We're labeling at
the protein level.
We're making the DNA to express
the fluorescent protein,
but we're actually labeling
a protein as opposed to DNA.
So A and B are out for sure,
but as we go through them,
you can start to see
the chromatin is red
and the tubulin is green, so
the outcome there would be,
whoops, what we're observing--
I thought what we're observing
is that the histones, which
are the proteins
associated with chromatin,
are labeled with a red protein.
And you can see that there.
Those are the chromatids,
and the tubulin,
these green fibrils, is
associated with a GFP.
So C would be the
correct answer there.
And there's another one of
these cell division pictures.
Once again, the same sort
of idea, but what I think
is really cool here, as
you can literally see,
I love this picture because
there's this poor chromosome.
It doesn't seem to be
able to get with the team.
He's hanging down there,
and, eventually, just
before cell division, it
seems like things work out OK
and cell division happens.
Now when you think
of this, the capacity
to watch this stuff in action
is really pretty amazing.
This was another one.
This a set of cell lines
where proteins in cell cycle
are labeled.
You had a question on
exam three about proteins
building up and going--
and going away during
parts of the cell cycle.
So, oftentimes, the
degradation of a protein
occurs when a protein gets
labeled with ubiquitin
by a ubiquitin
ligase, and then it
gets destined for degradation.
So the proteins that
you're seeing grow up
in phases of the cell
cycle are going away
because of the ubiquitin
proteasome system.
So in these cells, particular
proteins have been labeled,
and here you can
see the phases--
the components of the
cell cycle as proteins
come and go through
cell division,
and you can literally observe
where in the cell cycle
each individual protein is.
Why is this so
fascinating, I think,
in therapeutic development
is that you could literally
have drugs that might impact
aspects of the cell cycle,
and you could watch them in
real time impact the imaging
that you see on this screen
with the red and the green
because if you arrest at a
certain stage in cell cycle,
the cell will get stuck
at a particular color,
and you would even know which
phases, which parts of the cell
cycle, are being impacted.
So I think that's a really
sort of captivating way
to think of what you can
do with these proteins
because you can see
things in real time,
dynamics of cellular systems.
And I think, oh, and I'm going
to finish a few minutes early,
but I looked desperately
for a fluorescent turkey,
and I couldn't find one.
So I went with this light string
turkey and fluorescent colors.
It seemed to fit the bill.
All right, so please help
us finish up the bagels.
Make sure you guys over there
get them and have a good break,
and I'm passing you
back to Professor Martin
for Monday, which will be a
continuation of imaging, OK.